part of that word I know this is a big
moment it feels like whoa this is really
happening
what did Halle Bailey go through to film
her Little Mermaid scenes well she was
in the gym at 4am to prep and for these
underwater shots she was locked into a
harness that would help her spin to
emulate swimming when you got to see it
for the first time what was your oh my
goodness I watched it alone I was like
jaw dropped and just like tears like
non-stop flowing because you know I
consider myself a musician and singer
first I never seen myself on this big
screen before the add to that you're
making history you're the second
live-action black Disney princess yeah
it feels absolutely amazing to
officially be a Disney princess I mean I
think that it's something that we have
all just had in our dream so I just am
really grateful to be in this position
growing up did you watch Brandy as
Cinderella oh yeah yeah she was so
amazing such a role model and
inspiration
I know you have had to see these videos
this little black girls and how they
react to just seeing you it makes me
just emotionally overwhelmed honestly
and I cry as soon as I watch them
because I think of the little girl
that's still in me honestly and it heals
that girl inside of me and to watch them
feel like they have representation and
someone to look to to know that they
deserve to be in those places too
what I live for
tell you you did Ursula down
I'm not even kidding
kid perfectly I just think first of all
I thought how much whiskey and
um I well things that you shouldn't
smoke down there but I just thought
she's such a broad and she's damaged and
she's been alone a long time I fell so
in love with her I felt such empathy for
her this obsession with humans has to
stop now King Triton is the ultimate
helicopter
[Laughter]
your parents how do you compare him are
you strict over no no no no not even
close I'm far from far from that but
maybe my kids will say the opposite what
about for you Melissa a little a little
helicopter-ish I I like to call it
helping I don't think anyone else in my
house causes helping words to like you
want me to cut that for you and my kids
are like no we can cut our own but
that'll be like you want to cut up Apple
and they'll be like yes
[Music]
who else is in
this is in this Friday did Diggs play
Sebastian Jacob Tremblay is flounder and
Aquafina voices Scuttle
how much did you practice that Scuttle
squat only like when I was you know home
alone obviously it's not really like
it's something you do at a park you know